tout le monde sait toujours aussi
compact et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
pour un second best of open sur facebook
parce que vous l'avez demandé encore
encore et encore bien déconner avec et
qu'on lit comme d'habitude plein fouet
au rendez vous et pas mal de conneries
oui j'espère que ça va vous plaire et
puis a tout de suite
allez on change de plan 1 pourquoi sur
sept matches avec tout le temps je sais
pas avec ça s'appelle un gros problème
qu'aux horaires ce bug change d'armes
furent rares au monde allait surtout
surtout assez d'amis que j'irai autre
côté ça va très bien mais pas dont le pq
mais puisque ses deux chiens aussi mais
non mais qui est le mec c'est un rouleau
de pq il va dans la baignoire fin
qu'elle a eu jusque là bertomère de les
cayes courez courez courez courez petit
dossier de secrétaire été trouvé il
avait aucune liste dans ce que vous avez
fait les messes ont été parfaitement
symétrique que je vois deux étages et un
trop chaud mais j'ai vu c'est lui oui je
les ai vus j'ai vu un [ __ ] de nom
rouge doublé de mon écran voilà il était
là c'était toxique
c'était la fille c'est abominable de
twitter
au taquet n'accouche pas bouge pas ça va
le faire fais moi confiance j'ai
beaucoup d'expérience et chez qui la
surprend en cours
c'est
mais attention pas vrai je suis super
turquie allez tous vous faire [ __ ] je
suis et je suis super monkey ball
n'aurait jamais eu peur de choquer fait
des poubelles non non à ces annonces et
à qui le porte
je vais vous révéler au mérite
je me suis dit quel stade opow céder mon
dieu à l'essor très fière de ses cachets
il est comme ça en position foetale où
je souhaitais carto allez mika ont fait
la meilleure stratégie de la planète
allez au boulot au boulot karl a perdu
du temps on a perdu du temps en vue du
dj terre sortie en tonneaux tu étais en
papier à sortir aller plus vite plus
délicat même pas surpris que nous
je pense que l'équipe a scoré garde
alors effet qu on avait fait mal à ce
que je viens nous voir vous venez coupat
et bat pas l'union alors des late bas
vous venez pas de trouver bon alors je
jure de pâte à mâcher au fuse à la date
c'est facile de propane d'un achat
bloqué enfin allez allez à puce ou
attend toi dont les sept portes ouvertes
est en état d'arrestation de jeu qu'ils
aillent les l'ariary faisait les
poubelles ça t'apprendra à faire les
poubelles
josh holden pas
j'aurais agréé avocats ils y croient
encore à la grille je sautais au bon
moment qu'est ce donc
aulas me carnesi c'est bon ça ce n'était
pas une race and style non non ce n'est
pas une maison ce n'est pas mika l'eau
dans cette barrière
je veux pas passer au plus bas poussent
les pousse les we make up elle est comme
ça genre alors griquas les regarde il
regarde tous les barils et je ne sais
pas écrire au benfica ya des impacts de
balles sur trois a des impacts un peu
partout
non je rigole
puis je vous même fuir à dieu il est
public et alors ils étaient trop grillé
vsb pays sert à rien et il est comme ça
là toute la journée à bastia un tonneau
qui tombe du ciel alors déjà la première
et a bloqué la sortie à et là je suis je
me sens pas pousser au commando au juste
là il ya une équerre fait maison
oh là là quand on est bien sur l eau les
quais quand tu viens à fait aller
dépêche 5 4 ap 3-2
même technique de pincettes pour lui si
les cachets vécu comme un steak parce
que c'est une poêle vous avez compris il
est derrière un des poteaux voilà je me
dois avouer que je me dois de les aider
derrière précisément le quatrième poteau
ok ok mika est ce qu'on passe en bêta
mais qu est-ce qu on fera pareil port de
balès est partie mika appuyons-nous tant
que peuple adore la veille plus grille
et je crois que tu peux juste pas bon
alors le mec qui est là bas j'ai pris
trois séquences qui suit nos persos sont
tout seuls oui ils sont vraiment tout
seul et ne me demandez pas pourquoi j'ai
mis deux séquences de chansons j'en sais
rien vendu aux red hat pour gaël mais
condé comme aimantés quoi réagissent
m'approche et vocale tout a débuté vers
ben ali qui s'est passé je tiens à dire
à nos téléspectateurs que c'est pas du
petit mika high five
c'est quoi ce mec
alors quand tu veux que je prenne d'un
peu de ta boissons tu me l'envoie
autrement s'il te plaît déjà aux tirs au
but et en faire don à la porte dessus au
yoga vas-y michael et les deux danses
lui aviez tort je suis allé voir ma
croix on l'avait vu on l'avait prédit
soit en bas bas car cela fait taire les
canons et merde mais bloqué la veille
carthage trop dur août d'avancé à l'ohio
va les gars moi je vais là michael va t
on encore parler
et voilà j'ai aussi déjà fin de ce petit
best of numéro deux sur le mode propose
le garry's mod
j'espère que vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça me ferait
plaisir voilà on se retrouve
fournisseurs dans cette nouvelle vidéo
chaumont pis portez vous bien et je
renie pis
m
il